the brewmaster is essentially the chef
of the brewery so I'm responsible for
everything that has to do with the beer
from the concept the original concept of
the beer to the all the raw materials
all of the recipes all of the procedures
everything that has to do with having
the beer turn out the way that it's
supposed to and my job essentially ends
when your glass is empty and you
hopefully order another one so it really
is absolutely everything and you know
designing the brewery everything to do
with the EO with equipment etc so you
can think of it as being similar to the
chef who will conceive everything that
has to do with the food but also is
looking at things like you know does the
equipment the kitchen run properly house
the kitchen designed running the staff
in the kitchen all those sorts of things
are basically what the brewmaster does
well then when you look to build a
brewery your buildings if you're
building something from the ground up
it's different than if you're building
inside of an existing building you know
like it is for building a kitchen you
have to have conditions that can be made
sanitary you have to have obviously you
know the the right amount electricity
and water and everything else and you
have to have enough space for people to
work in you know space obviously to put
you know your tank at your equipment etc
and if you expect to be successful you
also have to have some space to expand
which makes it different than the
kitchen because usually when someone
goes to to start a restaurant they don't
say well suppose we do really well we'll
need a bigger kitchen and we'll have to
add more seats normally you're within a
confined space you have a kitchen that
can serve say these 200 seats and that's
what you have a brewery tends to be a
bit different most people will prefer a
space where they can expand a bit well a
good brewer has the idea in their head
of what of everything about the beer
before they started brewing it you can
see it smell it taste it everything
before you get started it's not supposed
to be an experiment yeah it's supposed
to come in the other direction where you
have a concept an idea you've been
inspired by these several things you
want to combine this with that whatever
it is and then you are figuring out
almost backwards engineering okay how do
i achieve this concept that i have and
that in a way is the art because you
know there is a blend of art and science
in in brewing or i should say in craft
brewing versus industrial brewing is
almost all science there is no art
however if you're doing craft brewing
which is brewing traditional beer for
flavor that's a whole different thing so
you know I have a concept first of what
the beer is going to be and then I work
backwards to see okay what do I need to
create this what ye strains what malts
what hop varieties you
what what temperatures at different
parts of the process and the thing about
brewing is that there is absolutely
nothing about it that doesn't count
every single last thing matters if you
do the math 155 degrees you will get a
different beer than if you do it at 158
degrees so it's it's it's all the little
minutia put together into one into one
thing there there certainly are ways to
do test brewing we don't do it i I've
been brewing professionally for 18 years
now and if I don't have a pretty good
idea of how it's going to turn out by
now it's probably time to pack the bags
and go home I'm not a big believer in
test brewing because it's just not
something that I think you can you can
get some basic ideas of things but most
people who are doing test proves of
things really they don't get out so much
so to speak they don't they don't do as
many different types of beer as we do so
I I think that we have a wide range of
experience about how to produce
different things now when you're doing
something which is completely different
than you've ever done before for example
we recently started doing beers which
are reefer mented in the bottle we did
run tests brews and really what we were
testing was not really the beer itself
because we knew how the beer would turn
out it was the bottle reform entation
part which basically nobody else in the
country is doing the way that we do it
and there really isn't any place to read
about how to do it or whatever else so
that was something where we felt like we
needed to do test bring and you know in
the last I can't remember how many years
it was pretty much the only time